- We'll get five topics
then we'll drop a beat and have some fun.
If you all sat in this section
what would you like to rap about?
- [Audience Member] Mole person love song.
- Mole person love song.
Thank you very much.
It feels like you've been
waiting your whole life
for someone to do that.
(audience laughing and clapping)
I'm so glad I could come
along and oblige. (chuckles)
This tranche here, what would you like?
- [Audience Member] Stoicism for cats
- What did you, Stoicism for cats?
- [Audience Member] Death and dying.
- What the fuck is going on here?
(audience laughing)
I like to know what gig I'm going into
and I asked one the
comics, the one I know.
How's the crowd?
And they said, genuinely
a really nice crowd.
I was like, great.
But you're fucking weird.
(audience laughing)
Mole person love song.
Stoicism for cats.
What there was another person
here who said something.
- [Audience Member] Death and dying.
- Did you say death and dying?
(audience laughing)
Death and dying. (laughs)
Death and Dying, mole person loves song
stoicism for cats.
Look, the next two suggestions
you can't fuck up because
these are God tear suggestions.
These are up there with some
of my personal favorites.
Like ninth century crop rotation
and Afghani irrigation ditches.
(audience laughing)
Let's go. What you'd wanna rap about?
- [Audience Member] The Emu War.
- The, the, the, oh you said
did you say The Emu War?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- Okay. Which was a genuine
you didn't think I knew about this.
This is a genuine war that
was fought in Australia
between the settlers who wanted some land
and the emus that lived on the land.
Fun fact, the emus did not lose the war.
It was
If you look this up on Wikipedia.
It's pretty much a stalemate.
There was even an injury
on the human side.
(audience laughing)
Someone accidentally shot themself.
Fun.
Yeah, you're surprised I
knew that. But then again.
Right mole person loves
song, death and dying
The Emu War. Cause I
misheard you at first.
I misheard the emo war.
I was like got a little
Paramore fan in the back.
(audience laughing)
Fuck My Chemical Romance.
Yeah, fuck 'em.
Fuck 'em.
And stoicism for cats.
This section what you'd want to rap about?
- [Audience Member] Claustrophobia.
- Claustrophobia. Great. Well done.
You know what annoys me when
people say I'm agoraphobic
which is the fear of
they say it's the fear of the
opposite of claustrophobic
fear of open spaces.
Tend the words of agoraphobic, right?
Agraphobia genuinely is
the fear of sexual assault.
There you go.
Just add the O.
Say a agoraphobic.
Never say agraphobic.
Just, you gotta put it in
because we're all agraphobic
I believe deep down inside.
Claustrophobia.
Claustrophobia
stoicism for cats, The
Emu war, death and dying
and mole person love song
fueled by illegal drink.
(audience cheering)
It's like we're in the 1920s.
Yeah, let's make sure
the proies don't come in.
Feel an illicit thrill running through me.
Because you may think
that this is like a hot
caffeinated beverage.
In fact, I was in a bar
drinking a beer and then I went
oh I have to come here but
I haven't finished my beer.
And they said, would you like
us to put it in a to go cup?
(audience cheering)
And that's a crime. That's illegal.
(audience laughing)
And I did a crime.
I'm here on a green card.
I could be deported.
This is.
(audience laughing)
I'm a rule breaker.
I mean look, the Queen's dead.
I can do whatever the fuck I want.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Yeah.
(audience cheers and claps continue)
I didn't even like the beer.
It was too hoppy.
(audience laughsing)
But I'm gonna drink it
cause I'm a big boy.
DJ Armstead, If you could
drop me that sick little beat.
(slow drum music)
Let's do this.
Yeah.
I'm glad you're all so politely excited.
♪ Bad rap would've left you crying. ♪
♪ I'm gonna ring it out. Why? ♪
♪ Cuz I'm death and dying. ♪
♪ I focus on this. ♪
♪ I've got a lot in funeral directing. ♪
♪ Stuff 'em in the coffin. ♪
♪ It's how I make my cash. ♪
♪ How I make my skrill. ♪
♪ I'm not Jack the Ripper
or a serial killer. ♪
♪ I'm just put in the ground. ♪
♪ Six feet under. ♪
♪ Dead people stealing the
thunder, plunder all the graves. ♪
♪ D and d, not Dungeons and Dragons. ♪
♪ Actually that's a lady with
a son there in the basement. ♪
♪ I've got a problem. ♪
♪ You know I'm gonna chase it. ♪
♪ I've got a tiny little
cat. It survives. ♪
♪ Persist. Why? ♪
♪ Cuz it's got nine lives. ♪
♪ Try and look at this
in the feline prism. ♪
♪ Back in the day, the Greek
stoicism went to shore. ♪
♪ I see Mr. Seneca, he says ♪
♪ gotta live a life ever so pure. ♪
♪ Connecting to death
got a value every day. ♪
♪ Imagine if that cat went away. ♪
♪ How would you tear with that? ♪
♪ You'd say, well I'm glad
I had the little moggy ♪
♪ in my life. Not bad. ♪
♪ That's how you'd be a stoic. ♪
♪ Even if you get exile to an
island nor wet from the tears ♪
♪ you can still enjoy your life. ♪
♪ We're moving over here. ♪
♪ Rap about a lady wife or
some other type of thing. ♪
♪ Yes, we can say keep her in a box ♪
♪ not a coffin naturally
but if she's in there ♪
♪ you know she throws it
up, she's claustrophobic. ♪
♪ Gets her bones frozen up. ♪
♪ Says ah, I can't face it. ♪
♪ Please release me
from the small spaces. ♪
♪ It's ever so difficult. ♪
♪ You know, I lost it. ♪
♪ I'm in there maybe
trapped in the closet. ♪
♪ That's an R. Kelly reference. ♪
♪ I don't know why. ♪
♪ Jesus Christ, you like me. Oh my. ♪
♪ But I talked about ♪
♪ the sexual assault and
so it linked in my brain. ♪
♪ It's not my fault. ♪
♪ What we gonna do? ♪
♪ Have a lot of fun. ♪
♪ I've got a person I
love deep underground. ♪
♪ They live round there in the hole. ♪
♪ Got a weird star nose ♪
♪ tiny little mole living underground ♪
♪ and they never see the light. ♪
♪ They're like, no one will
love me throughout my life. ♪
♪ What am I going to do? ♪
♪ I feel so bereft. ♪
♪ Used to have a
boyfriend, but they left. ♪
♪ I'm in here. I feel so crazy. ♪
♪ I get on Tinder ♪
♪ and the mole lady and I see
her, you know I like her. ♪
♪ The mole lady. ♪
♪ Why? So, I swipe her. ♪
♪ I go and visit her. ♪
♪ There in a little den. ♪
♪ I say, whoa girl
you're a 10 out of 10. ♪
♪ And we start doing it. ♪
♪ She likes it large. ♪
♪ She goes, yeah, yeah. ♪
♪ You know, we're fucking in the dark. ♪
♪ She's really good. ♪
♪ And a mole pussy tight. ♪
♪ I know it'd be sick, but
she can't see the light. ♪
♪ Wanna go to a nightclub? ♪
♪ Get a nice rub. ♪
♪ She's pretty cool. Yeah. ♪
♪ Digging with a thumb in my bum. ♪
♪ I like it a lot. ♪
♪ The mole person starts
humming on the male G spot. ♪
♪ This is genuinely very unsettling. ♪
♪ There was one thing remaining. ♪
♪ One thing left in remind me. ♪
♪ I had too much fun rapping
about the mole person's thumb ♪
♪ in my bum. ♪
♪ What was the last thing that we do? ♪
(upbeat music)
Just one person say it.
Cause if you all say it once
it's just like a massive noise.
Of course.
♪ How could I forget is so absurd. ♪
♪ I observe this the life
of a flightless bird. ♪
♪ They say, ah yeah we
could have lost it ♪
♪ but we won emu strong.
Fuck the ostrich. ♪
♪ Those one black white
feathers in the day. ♪
♪ I prefer the emus beige and gray. ♪
♪ They'd be there in Australia. ♪
♪ I'll say to you the
accent they attack it. ♪
♪ They aim for sure. ♪
♪ Ah fuck, we're gonna mount'em
down in their hoards. ♪
♪ All the emus are like now up yours. ♪
♪ We're gonna defeat you. ♪
♪ You'll be bereft. ♪
♪ We're really fucking dense. ♪
♪ And our flesh just
absorbs all the bullets ♪
♪ from the gatling gun. ♪
♪ We've got really long legs. ♪
♪ You should watch us run. ♪
♪ And we do. We dominate. ♪
♪ Yeah, I'll say fuck Australians ♪
♪ for killing emus every single day. ♪
(audience cheering loudly)